we've successfully avoided talking at
least directly about polling this week
but I think it does make sense since
we're just a few days out from the
election to do a quick review of where
things stand right now there's been the
talking point this week from Trump
surrogates if you've been paying
attention to corporate media and if you
haven't congratulations that the race is
tightening and the Trump surrogates say
it's tightening we're doing well in
early voting in Florida we're just doing
well and it's tightening and Trump is
right in this thing is that true well
fortunately we have data we can look at
to figure out if that is indeed the case
let's first start with just recent
polling this is from the Real Clear
Politics average of recent polling and
you'll notice if it's tightening it's
still looking pretty good for Democratic
presidential candidate Hillary Clinton
if you look at this list of polls that
I'm showing you and we'll go through a
few different things on it at the very
very bottom of this list and this is
about 20 polls deep right you will see
that in the Rasmussen Reports poll back
from the middle of October Donald Trump
is plus two and there's been some noise
made about Oh rats mucin has Trump back
in the lead
yeah not really I mean there have been
moments where in the tracking it Trump
has taken a small lead but even the most
recent Rasmussen Reports polls that you
see you see one for ending on October
26th you see another one on this list
ending October 25th its Clinton +1
Rasmussen is certainly the one that is
the best for Donald Trump but no Donald
Trump is not even winning in that one
and at the very top of that image if we
can put it back up for a second you will
notice the Real Clear Politics average
of recent polls this is four weig
polling data which has Hillary Clinton
ahead by about five and a half points
Gary Johnson starting to trail off
exactly as I predicted he would do now
below 6% average and Jill Stein the
Green Party candidate she had been at
one point polling an average of about
three to four percent even five in some
polls
I said unequivocally that Jill Stein
will not get 5% of the
nor even 4% of the vote and she has now
settled at 1.8 percent okay so
nationally a slight tightening maybe
there was one point at which Hillary
Clinton held about a six and a half to
seven point average lead nationally in
all polls that now is about five and a
half points a slight tightening we can
say but it's not that tight right now
but as you know we do not have a
national popular vote election here we
have an electoral college actually some
people emailed me saying David you've
got to say Electoral College not
electoral I've always said electoral I
don't know I think I'm gonna proceed
that way Pat unless you have any strong
feeling about it no I barely even
noticed the difference yeah it's good
that's that's exactly what I like to
hear so what is going on state by state
electoral E or electoral II depending on
who you are and how you want me to
pronounce it there's been discussions of
Florida's going in the direction of
Donald Trump Nevada going in the
direction of Donald Trump right now
based on state polls both electoral vote
calm and 538 forecasts have Florida and
Nevada for Hillary Clinton let's take a
look now at the map from this morning on
electoral vote calm and you will see
that they have Florida they have Nevada
they have Pennsylvania and Virginia and
North Carolina and a number of other
states that Donald Trump as recently as
yesterday claimed were toss-ups they
have them in the Hillary Clinton camp
no ties currently according to electoral
- vote comm based on their map Hillary
Clinton if the election were held today
would end up with about three hundred
and twenty three electoral votes way
more than the number required to be the
next president of the United States
Donald Trump 215 electoral votes way
fewer than the number required to be
President of the United States
so let's now round out our discussion of
the numbers and then we can move on to
other things with nate silver's
fivethirtyeight.com
forecast how have the chances of winning
changed over time and you will see that
after reaching
highpoint in sort of around the 10th or
12th of october there has been a very
slight decrease in Hillary Clinton's
chances of winning the election on
November 8th and a very slight uptick
for Donald Trump
Hillary Clinton had reached a high of
about 88 or 89 percent chance of winning
the November 8th election that has
dropped to eighty four point seven
percent as of this morning
according to the fivethirtyeight.com
forecast so it's weird Pat because if we
just say oh the race is tightening well
Hillary Clinton's lead has been reduced
a little bit Hillary Clinton's chance of
winning according to fivethirtyeight.com
has been reduced a little bit but big
picture there has not been a big change
and we're running out of days for Donald
Trump here the change probably has to do
with the Billy Bush tapes starting to
blow over at this point it was funny too
because back in the primaries Trump
would go on and on about how he was
winning in the polls yeah and he's
somehow become silent now that he's
losing yeah he does still every once in
a while when he shows up at speeches say
believe me we're winning the elections
rigged the polls are rigged the media's
rigged the entire thing is rigged you
can't trust the polls we're going to dig
into that a little bit more later in the
show